ça fait vraiment mal au cœur après toute
cette soirée de devoir tout retirer
mais pourtant il va falloir
c'est là que tu te dis mais comment ça
tient tout ça
c'est vraiment du fait sur la peau quoi
il y avait du coton dedans vous avez
l'envers du décor les plus
j'ai le bras tout en
gros à droite comme ça
ok je fais quoi je coupe avec mais non
regarde tu prends le dos de ton assiette
et tu vas aiguiser ton couteau avec ça
je viens de voir
s'endormir donc le mec dit il faut
ouvrir les yeux puis fermer les yeux
ouverts les yeux
fermez les yeux
[Musique]
alors Inès Van Damme elle a tellement
peur que je l'oublie en une semaine
parce que ça fait une semaine qu'on a
pas d'encens ensemble et je ne t'oublie
pas Inès alors vas-y que je te fais une
campagne Mauboussin des quatre partras
dans tout Paris et maintenant
voilà nom des rues
je ne t'oublie pas Inès oh là là
mon ex elle me faisait des pizzas maison
des lasagnes des pâtes on allait au McDo
on se des trucs de ouf et toi tu me fais
une salade c'est quoi ton problème
tu restes avec moi j'en ai marre je vais
te quitter ouais